welcome back Sarah barelis is with us
give it up
everybody Sarah has many passionate fans
I am one um what's your craziest Fan
Experience well I did crowd surf one
time that was a very fun which people
which I like saying that to people
because people are like you crowd surf
like really I would say that you would
crowd surf really yeah you seem fun and
wild how you crowd surf 100% not at my
shows but at the toes at Food Fighters
at like all yeah I was I was one of
those people like in a brawl sweating in
the mge pit lik yes I love that's not
shocking that's not shocking news yeah I
love this I it feels good it's so
powerful and everyone's like now it's so
funny cuz I'm a I I don't I wouldn't do
that now cuz I'm like oh you're really
sweaty like like but in my teens I I
didn't care yeah yeah no I was I was on
stage and there was a technical
difficulty and I think I just like
panicked and was like fill the time and
and that was your favor
everything went
to great ideas I think it's amazing yeah
it was very fun it was very fun I think
that's really fun I think that you're
funks um so wait do you like to involve
fans with your show because both I think
we're similar in this too I like
intimate shows I do too I played the
arena kind of vibe I've even Stadium but
I love a theater that is my favorite
it's it's something I've been thinking a
lot about as I think about next record
and what will happen and I as much as I
love the big shows there is nothing
better than feeling like you can
actually be in ation with your like
you're in their living room like I love
yeah I love that me too yeah I learned
that from Garth Brooks I saw him in
Vegas and it was just he and his guitar
and it was like that's really special it
is because not everybody can do that a
lot of people need like a big production
yeah and sometimes big Productions are
fun to watch I just for the majority I'd
rather see like Annie Linux in a theater
like I did see her in London like that
and I was oh well I wanted to quit so
well yeah I was like oh I do something
cute every now and then um so yeah I was
like oh that's like a real artist
but
[Music]
[Applause]
anyway thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home